welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Star
Wars and or episode 5 that ax forgets
which is a relief because I forced way
too much ax on a smelly day to Revenge
of the Sith and I hope no one remembers
it from Indiana Jones Easter eggs to
just downright Great Character details
let's break down everything that you
might have missed in this episode
composer Nicholas Patel's music
continues to evolve over the titles
Episode by episode this time adding some
piano notes to the mix
foreign
[Music]
now this title of the ax forgets comes
from the rebel Arville skins line later
the ax forgets what the tree remembers
he's referring to how oppressors tend to
forget their crimes but the wounded
never forget and despite this episode
focusing so much on the victims of the
Empire it's not titled the tree
remembers and I think it's because we
are all axes and trees in different ways
to different people we tend to remember
how we've been scarred but not the scars
that we leave on others Cassie and Andor
for example totally a victim a tree
scarred in his own ways but also an ax
and others and one of the victims of his
cutting Cyril Karn a tree deeply scarred
and that's we start with this episode
sunlight briefly beams in before fading
on his face it was implied from that
Spaceport scene last episode that this
metropolan world could be hosnian prime
future Capital the new Republic after
the Empire Falls and if so a blinding
light in the sky of this planet totally
foreshadows the apocalyptic end of
hosnian prime by the first order maybe
two a destined Doom for Karn disguised
as a Heavenly Spotlight each storyline
this episode begins with a kind of
breakfast and on the table of this
breakfast are some fruits that look like
Malu run the fruit popular from Rebels
and the book above it but these fruits
are smaller than they are in the book of
Boba Fett they actually look more like
real world kiwano melons his mother Edie
played by Catherine hunter figg from
order to Phoenix and the witches from
the tragedy Macbeth pours him cereal
with blue a bantha milk and his puff
cereal that kind of looks like oops all
berries he holds one and stares at it
probably wishing he were on a doom space
station in this shape instead of here
with his mom she nags you're slouchy by
the time you've remembered to sit up
straight it's too late you might as well
wear a sign that says I promise to
disappoint you yeah this is a real
trigger for of the Moody boys of this
episode shoulders back
more don't touch me you want something
you tell me Cyril spends time staring at
cassian's mug shot and I think these two
are on Parallel trajectories because if
you think about it the only real
Prospect available to Cyril at this
point through his uncle Harlow might be
the Rebellion something Cyril might try
out as a way to get closer to Cassian we
could totally imagine a scenario where
these two are on a mission together and
then uh whoa because AS Val later says
everyone has their own Rebellion Cassian
wakes up to find skein going through his
stuff including his k-19 Briar pistol
the same Blaster used by Kyle katarn in
the dark Forces game and that corporate
Blaster that Cassian got from the three
more cops in episode one as Cassian
approaches his eyes drop to skeen's
tattoo
Craighead what about this
by the hand yes skein's chest tattoo has
a barcode meaning this is some kind of
prison registry and crate head is a
reference to the crate Dragon which
might have been skein's prison gang now
by the hand could be an odd to the path
of the open hand from Tessa Gratton and
Justina Ireland's New Path of Deceit
from the high Republic series published
literally this week wait no look at some
probably it outlines a bit for months
now this story follows a culty nihil
gang who believed the force should no
longer be used but Augusta hands there's
also a group of Palpatine operatives
from Legends called The Emperor's hand
marriage Aid Luke Skywalker's wife was a
member of it and the Rebels Episode
Legacy of Mandalore confirmed this group
exists in Canon even if Mara Jade
remains non-canon for now it would be
crazy for skiing to be involved in
either of these groups I think he may
have just gotten this tattoo as a
reference to the nikhil ideology Skeen
asks Cassian how he knows these so where
were you
simple
Youth Center
three years I was 13 when I went in we
built a lot of cages huh
the ax forgets but the tree remembers
now it's our turn to do The Chopping I
remember Cassian did have a prior mug
shot in Imperial records claiming he was
from best so he likely did some time
before he was forced to fight in mimbot
skein's reference to the episode title
is also him referencing his brother a
pepper tree farmer and as he walks away
he passes and acts and freshly cut
firewood meaning that it was skeen's
morning chores and brother remembrance
that likely cause him to work up this
sweat that required this bath another
breakfast scene shows this mon Mata with
her husband Perrin drivers here
chloris
you know his name yeah I love the
subtextual storytelling there mine has a
new driver who's been spying on her but
the fact that Perrin doesn't know the
new driver suggests that he's completely
removed from the spycraft he's super
ignorant but also we learned they have a
daughter Lida who changes the routine
and says that daddy's taking me to
school today the point is we have a
schedule the driver's waiting I've
planned on this and we're going you're
only doing it to show off what sky
what would I be showing off
you're involved somehow yeah man's
planned routine likely involved her
using this schedule to connect with her
Rebel contacts every move she makes has
to be carefully planned so leader
altering the schedule mucks all that up
indeed manmatma is using this girl for
show but for more than just political
posturing but to truly have a convincing
cover identity for the Empire who is
watching her it's also pretty sad to
think that when mon matma goes on the
lamb to publicly join the Rebellion
following the Gorman Massacre she will
be leaving behind a daughter nemec pours
Cassie and his breakfast Trey milk
you can live on that you may question
Your Existence after a few days
remember but isn't it yeah nemec is
obsessed with memorable true moments
because he believes the Empire is
brainwashing everyone this Series has
been so concerned with an imperial star
path unit but nemic shows Cassian an old
starpath unit oh and true he's sturdy
one of the best navigational tools ever
built can't be jammed or intercepted
something breaks you can fix it yourself
hard to learn yes but once you've
mastered it you're free this prop is
actually the backside of a Polaroid sx70
camera from 1972 and I love that they
use an early 70s Appliance to hearken
back to the beat up analog Tech look
from the 1977 Star Wars film they use a
super analog camera something that
literally prints the photograph on film
in your hand basically the oldest type
of practical working camera that we'd
have in our world mimic rants there's a
growing list of things we've known and
forgotten things they've pushed us to
forget things like freedom
that makes these oppression everywhere
yeah nimik explains the psychology of
the Empire's fascist control by using
Imperial technology people have allowed
themselves to become enslaved also
noticed during the scene how Cassian
observes how skein is drinking with his
left hand this is the moment that Kassim
registers all of their handedness like
later when he says nemec favors is right
but shoots with his left mimic in this
scene holds his star path in his right
hand but keeps his true moral compass
his Manifesto in his left but damn it
goes on the pace of repression outstrips
our ability to understand it and that is
the real trick of the Imperial Thought
Machine it's easier to hide behind 40
atrocities and a single incident oof
speak truth I would love to see mimic in
a speed debate with part of gas we are
Healthcare Providers provide yourself
you've grown addicted an addiction
willingly subscribed to by alien
patients ignored by the cruelties of
freedom freedom to have an open
invitation to attempt to cure nemec says
our Elemental rights are such a simple
thing to hold they will have to shake
the Galaxy awfully hard to loosen our
great yeah nemec is using the same grip
metaphor that Leia uses on Tarkin the
more you tighten your grip talk the more
star systems will slip through your
fingers but nemec sees meaning in
everything including what is currently
in his hands two seemingly random
objects and yet this charts an astropath
this Maps the trail of political
Consciousness both systems based on
truth both navigating to all clear and
achievable outcomes and I love what this
means for Cassian the path ahead in the
Stars through the eye of aldani is the
same kind of thing as the path toward
political Awakening for him if you're
loving Andor as much as I am and you
want a fun way to commemorate this cool
show all season long the Star Wars card
Trader by tops is dropping weekly card
sets after every episode airs last week
I got this cool one of mon matma
cruising up to Lutheran's antique shot
from episode 4. Star Wars cartrade by
tops lets you open Digital packs to
collect your favorite Star Wars
characters weapons and moments it's not
just and or characters get yourself a
Leia grogu a cad Bane too once you open
the packs you can connect and trade
cards with fans across the Galaxy to
complete sets get free cards and credits
daily to grow your collection you can
complete missions to unlock unique
content or craft your cards into rarer
ones at the workbench they're always
releasing new card sets so the fun of
collecting never has to end join me now
on Star Wars card Trader by tops by
downloading the game from the link in
this video's description and find me on
there under the username new rockstars
Max and propose a trade now the sheep
livestock is a real world British breed
called Jacob's sheep that commonly have
four horns but they actually added an
additional prosthetic pair to make six
I've heard some speculation that these
might be Nerfs as in you know a scruffy
looking nerd herder but that hasn't been
confirmed Lieutenant Gorn arrives at the
temple what's this
target practice yes we learned later
this episode that he fell in love with
the local woman his discipline in this
case is truly rooted in genuine respect
for the aldani's sacred sites back on
Barracks supervisor blevin oversees a
cleanup from Karen's mess back in
episode 3 appointing Captain Tigo as the
prefix giving him the hotel as his new
Imperial headquarters which includes his
laundry device with a garment bag I
assume it is Willy's because you know
that guy probably paid an arm and a leg
for dry cleaning an imperial cph
Speeder Bike floats up to the left we
actually first saw one of these chasing
Han and Kira on corellia in Solo a Star
Wars story and as the Imperials March
past the editing perfectly syncs with
the aldani rebels marching to practice
looking like these Imperials Cassian
proves he knows what hand they all shoot
with and suggests to switch formation so
that their guns are on the outside I
assume next episode is going to be
pretty important on the mission and then
a TIE fighter buzzes past and it
reappears over the crest two in a really
low flyover
foreign
I love how the humans Duck and Cover
their ears but the Sheep unfazed why
because Jacob's sheep suck at acting
they refuse to react to the effects on
the set shouldn't put me in the volume
mimic says they'll soon see
surprise from above is never shocking as
one from Below
ultimately this will prove true in the
Battle of Scarab Cassian and his team in
that battle will be able to bring down a
threat from above the freaking death
star with an assault from the ground
below on the scarf's surface since it
quizzes Cassian in the aldani language
hello not a boy again Natalie
stop
an issue
Niche it's hard now fionasha told us
that they created actual functional
languages for this show and I tried to
find the linguist on the staff but so
far I've only found Marina Tyndall
credited as a dialect coach now in the
real world all spoken languages have a
practicality in how they evolve and I
like how in this case the word for stop
has a heart as opposed to soft phonetic
pronunciation at the end of the word h
as opposed to Niche at the isbedramiro
brainstorms in her investigation posnee
Prime it's useless they haven't broken
misplaced or mislabeled a single
military component in the last 12
quarters yeah hosnian Prime coming up
again which might be where Karen is
located and thus how we could tie back
into this miro's Aid says you're on to
something
Castle
fondor targeting consoles from jakku
proton Warheads from base K the steer
guard star path so these are all the
past cases that dejramir has been trying
to connect Kessel could refer to the
events of solo a Star Wars story where
Han and his crew stole coaxium that
Starship fuel from the Pikes on Kessel
which ended up in the hands of the Rebel
group The Cloud writers one of the cloud
writers is benthic two tubes brother to
edrio two tubes member of Saw guerrera's
partisans and based on a shot in one of
the late and or trailers entrio will
appear later in the season fondor is the
shipyard Planet seen in Battlefront 2
from which Lutheran got his fandor Hall
craft which remember is mysteriously
equipped with a hyperdrive jakku is a
desert planet from the force awakens
future set into the Battle of shaku and
where Rey grew up and decades before
this series Palpatine began an
archaeological digong jakku all to prep
for his later Sith Observatory from
which he will postmortem orchestrate his
operation
contingency plan to Scorch all planets
proton Warheads go on the tip of proton
torpedoes and of course steer guard
where the star path unit was taken
sagarra is at least benefiting from all
these incidents but as someone in hiding
anyway I don't think he really cares the
Empire finds out what he does he might
even prefer it because he's like a
terrorist instead I think Detroit's
investigation is going to lead to
Lutheran who said this episode that he
hasn't really been careful and I think
when he gets exposed that's going to
force mon mothma to cut him off to
maintain her deception and her status in
the Senate Goran reprimands his men with
an engineering officer from Coruscant
arriving today and in our business yeah
another reference to this Coruscant
engineer whom I think we see arriving in
that Imperial shuttle later on whoever
this is it could have been a major
Wrinkle in their mission maybe a VIP
that the rebels have to choose whether
or not to assassinate or stay focused on
their mission or if they have some
bigger booms planned for this damn a
dead VIP that's going to make this
Mission an even bigger blip for the
Empire skiing rages about the Crystal
kyber Sky kyber gonna storm War 30 000
credits yeah skin is lowballing that
Luther said not to take less than 50 000
for this Crystal but Vel quells the Feud
yet still casting comes clean to them
I'm here for the money
you can't live with that I'm not worth
it I'll walk away and wish you luck so
by telling them all the truth Cassian
just lays down their cards so that they
know his motives pairing challenges
Monmouth about not telling them about
this new charity Foundation which he
probably hid from her husband because
this is how she's gonna move some Rebel
funds around Skeen reveals to Cassie and
what his personal Rebellion is his
brother was a pepper tree farmer whose
land was flooded by an imperial prefect
and his brother drowned himself so Alex
cousin gotta make the Jordan era without
some bell peppers but this Revelation
also gives greater weight for skein to
attack this Imperial Dam this damn
damned a sacred River and flooded a
valley displacing thousands of farmers
so in every single one of those Farmers
Skeen will see his brother it might get
hard for him to not get emotional
tomorrow Belle splits up with cinta on a
side part of the mission that they won't
tell Cassian as the two women of the
group maybe there's some role to play as
aldani priestesses maybe his friends of
the commandant's wife like I mentioned
earlier remember there was a little
moment earlier where Cintas said that
she rigged the charges that they're
going to use in some way in this Mission
so maybe they could be on their own
suicide mission to blow this damn after
castian departs it leaving him as a sole
survivor with the payload and that's why
it was so important for Lutheran to have
him on this Mission and actually if you
think about it it could be an even
bigger deal than he thought when he
insisted on piloting the freighter
earlier back when he shamed them for not
knowing how to calibrate the weight
because by moving himself in the pilot
position and telling Val you'll still
get the credit for it he might have
accidentally shifted the roles around so
that Belle would stay behind maybe we'll
see how it goes in Lutheran's shop on
the shelf behind him are some big Easter
eggs and I mean big because those Jedi
and Sith holocrons are way larger than
they are when we see them elsewhere in
Star Wars titles but I don't know if
these are real holocrons they may just
be in large replicas of them but I don't
know why they would have replicas of
these things it's not like they're
widely known but even crazier than these
beside them to the right are the Sankara
stones from Indiana Jones and the Temple
of Doom now this isn't the only broader
lucasfilm family Cameo as the final shot
shows three Carbonite plates we saw them
better at last episode in the interior
shot the outermost one shows Indiana
Jones whip beneath that President
Carbonite is the golden idol from the
temple in Raiders and beneath Frozen
Carbonite or Indiana Jones famous Alden
boots and there is a long history of
Star Wars and Indiana Jones referencing
each other R2 and 3PO are among the
hieroglyphics by the Ark of the Covenant
shanghai's Club Obi-Wan and Temple of do
a barrel on the boat and the Last
Crusade with a Portuguese word for
Carbonite the golden idol cameos among
Dragon boss's items in Solo Star Wars
story and various shared sound effects
from the lucasfilm archives sometimes
Easter eggs are just meant to be fun
like I don't think we're meant to read
too much into Lutheran having the lothal
tablets or plokon's mask or the
Starkiller armor when it comes to how
important these Easter eggs are it
really just depends on the director
because when Dave vellone includes
Easter eggs and his Star Wars titles I
think he wants us to be like deadrazine
it's too random to be random follow me
on Tick Tock Instagram and Twitter at
eavos follow new Rockstar subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]